.
In this presentation, we will learn how to take the distance
Between any two points on the axes x and y, and
We'll see, it's just an application
Pythagoras
Let's start with an example
Let's assume I have the point, I'll write it in dark
So we can see it on the graph sheet
Let's assume that I have a pinch 3, -4
If I wanted to represent her, I would go 1, 2, 3 and
I will move to 4 at the bottom
1, 2, 3, 4 Here, these are 3, -4
Suppose also that I have point 6.0
If 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, then there is no movement in
Direction y
We take a position only on the x-axis
Axis y = 0, this is the point 6,0
What I want to find is the distance between these two
Two points
How much after this blue dot about this orange point?
First, I do not think we are
We have already seen how to find
Such a distance
What were you talking about Pythagorean theory?
I do not see triangles here!
If you do not see a triangle, let me
I draw it for you
I will draw a triangle
Let me draw this triangle here, so
Let me use several colors
Share the point completely
If this is the triangle
Perhaps you will realize quickly
This is a triangle
This is our existing triangle
Its base is moving straight from left to right, and the right side is heading
Straight from top to bottom, we are dealing with an existing triangle
If we can find the length of the base and
In this case, we can even use Pythagoras' theorem
We find the long rib, the opposite rib
For the right angle, ie the tendon
This distance is a tendon
Triangle based
Let me write this down
This distance is equal to the tendon
This triangle exists
Let me paint it more
If this is the chord
Then we have the right rib, the rib that moves
From top to bottom
Then we have the rule
Now, how can we find - call me
My name is this d relative to the distance
This is the length of the tendon
How to find the length of the descent from top to bottom
This rib?
Let's look at the rule first, how much is this distance?
You can count them on this graph sheet, but here
Where x = - let me use the green color
Here, we point to x = 3, here on x =
6, right?
We move straight to the right
This is the same distance there
So we find that distance, ie
End of point x
You can move in the other direction, because you
You will rip everything up, it does not matter if you get it
Negative numbers, if the distance here equals 6
-3, is not it?
6, -3
This distance, which is equal to 3
If we have created the rule
To remind ourselves, this is equal
To change the x
This was equal to the final x point -
Starting point
This is delta x
Now, following the same line of reasoning, rise
Here is the change in y
Above we will be at y = 0
Perhaps this is the end point
It's the top point on y
Here, we will be y = -4
Change in y = 0-4
All I do is take a higher value for y - less
The value for y, the highest value for x - the lowest value for x
But we will see that we will square them
Quickly, even if you do it in another way, you'll
You get a negative number, but you'll still get the same
Answer, if this equals 4
This rib equals 4
You can also count on the graph sheet if you like
This rib equals 3
Now we can use the theory of Pythagoras
This distance is a square distance
be cerfull
Space box = delta x ^ 2
Any square change in x, +
Change box in y
There is nothing fantastic
Sometimes some people call it the distance formula
It's Pythagorean theory
This square is the square + that side =
The chord box, because this triangle is present
So let 's apply them to these numbers, ie setups
In our hands
Space box = delta x ^ 2
Ie 3 ^ 2 + Delta y ^ 2, ie + 4 ^ 2
Which equals 9 + 16, and equals 25
If the distance is equal - let me write it - d ^ 2
= 25
d, any distance, = - we do not want to take
Negative square root, because we can not have
Negative distance, he square root
The square root is positive for 25, which equals 5
If this distance is equal to 5
Or if you look at this distance, where it was
The original issue
How much after this point about that point?
It is 5 units away
What you see here, is called the distance formula
But Pythagorean theory
And even exposed to all the ways that
You will encounter a formula of distance, sometimes some people may say
If I have two points, if one, let's call it
x1 and y1, if this point
Let's assume that I have another point is x2, y2
You will sometimes see this formula, where the distance -
You'll see it in different ways
But you will see that the distance = - and
Looks like a complicated formula
But I want to see this
Phitagors theory
As you see that the distance = x2 - x1) ^ 2)
+ y2 - y1) ^ 2)
As you can see, this is written in a systematic way
Distance formula
It is simply a loss of your time if you want to save it
It is a theory of Pythagoras
This is the change in x
In fact it does not matter which x we ​​will choose to be first
Or second, because even if you get a negative image of these
When you square it, the negative sign disappears
This is the change in y
It shows that the space box - remember
If you cross the two sides of the equation, the root symbol
The space box will disappear
The box for this statement equals delta x ^ 2
The change in x-delta means the amount of change - delta x ^ 2
+ Delta y ^ 2
I do not want to bother you
Delta y means the change in y
Maybe I should say it at the beginning of the show
But let me apply this to more examples, and I will pick some
Points randomly
Let's assume that I have a point, let's say, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
6, -4-
Let's assume I want to find the distance between that and
1, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, and 1.7, then
I want to find the distance here
It's the same idea
We will use the theory of Pythagoras
We will find the distance, ie the change in x, this
The distance, ie the change in y
Square this space + box this distance
= Square this distance
Let's do it
The change in x, we take -
As you know, it does not matter
In general, we want to take the greatest value for X-
The smallest value for x, but you can do it in another way
Cats can write the space box = - what is
Change in x?
Let's take a larger value for x-smaller value for x, ie 1 -
(1 - 6) ^ 2 + change in y
The biggest value for y here
Are 7
(7-4) ^ 2
I have chosen these numbers randomly, if
The outcome will not be clear
We get the space box = 1 -
A7, 7 ^ 2, and you'll see it here too
If you count
We go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7
This issue is here
This is the change in x
+ 7 - -4
= 11
This is the distance, and you can play after
The squares
We move to the top by 11
We take 7 - -4 to get
The distance is 11
If + 11 ^ 2 = d ^ 2
Let me get out the calculator
If the distance if we take 7 ^ 2 + 11 ^ 2
= 170, and that distance is equal to the square root
So, right? d ^ 2 = 170
If we take the square root of 170 we get 13.0
Approximately 13.04
This is the distance we tried
Find it is 13.04
I hope you found this useful